what's up man
it's good uh how are you enjoying uh BT
weekend well it's over now it's Monday
but yeah
it's Tuesday I don't even know we'd be
rapping if you feel me have man happy
about right now you Vamp yeah you got
the new album half man half Vamp which
is uh explain are you like do you not
sleep a lot do you bite [__] in the
neck and suck their blood are you like
uh are you into like scared of garlic or
what's going on nah you know the [__]
do get hooked though okay but nice
there's on some [__] like
that's when when you feel me that's when
I go to work Strictly Business standing
on the business you know what I'm saying
have man you know that's that's when I'm
taking care of responsibilities in the
daytime all the responsibilities that I
created as a man family I love you feel
me for being the father of Big Brother
you know I'm saying little brother being
the uh of sun can I tell you what we
call Vamps in my friend group what's up
I have a friend and I'm not even lying
right now
shout out to the baby dude
we call him a vampire because he ate his
girl out while she was on her period oh
my God he's a real vampire just a
[__] psycho he got me beat yeah
yeah he we say he's got his red he's got
his Red Wings you know sit down so I
mean I don't mind you know the the
period relations if you got the shower
and you know if it's Britney's going
crazy
so yo talk to me man because obviously
Jacksonville is one of the hottest
cities in hip-hop it's been uh very very
highly publicized a lot of the violence
that transpires out there
um
what do you think if anything can be
done to try to bring
I guess a lot more unity in Jacksonville
no it's really
it's really unity in Jacksonville
you just you know I'm saying everybody
everywhere you go you know I'm saying
everybody not gonna like each other or
be a parties I think I would be like
that so
the unity is not saying that the way it
is now you feel me it's good in fact
it's getting better yeah everybody just
gotta you know I'm saying build around
that you feel me everybody might not be
on the same thing you can't force that
you feel me but as long as you on the
same page you know what I'm saying this
building trying to grow that's all that
matters 100 man what it's like for you
because you've been grinding
independently for so long what has been
the biggest thing that you've learned
since coming with CMG because obviously
you know I always say it like the
hottest label in the world you know what
I'm saying like it's really like the
modern day death Rowan chain so for you
coming into such a it's like the
All-Star team yeah you know what I mean
it's crazy when you really go through
the roster what is some stuff you've
picked up
the future matters you know what I'm
saying but the brand you know I'm saying
that's it build the brand you know what
I'm saying like
right now you see how you saying like
CMG and he and got it got his artist you
feel me he making sure that that them
artists building their brand in the
process and you know what I'm saying
you know he's female getting no better
than that you know what I'm saying the
brand that's all that matter having
something in the years from now there's
no I'm saying that that's still here
you're feeling like he did I like that
I would say who's the starting five of
CMG and then who's the Sixth Man or
woman
um
I can't put everybody you know what I'm
saying Yo Gotti's like LeBron James or
Michael Jordan right type [__] or you
know what he's like Greg Popovich okay
you're trying to put like together like
like just like the starting five there's
any anywhere type [__] okay boom yeah
you got your your Jordan
if you got it
say God I feel like God should be he's
the coach he's like the Hall of Famer
turn coach I'm serious man okay you're
the sixth man I'm coming out the bench
you're Lou Williams I'm coming out the
bench for show for sure you know I'm
saying you can always depend on me to
come out the benching and throw 25 up
win a game easy win a game seven easy
you feel me so one thing about that
starting five they know they can depend
on Pablo they can depend on you to come
on clean up
call me it's